.
Let us resolve some of the issues that concern the agreements
Fields and ranges
As a simple review, conjugation is a factor - called us
Say that this is the f-coupling; it is the most commonly used character
In the bindings - Runs a specific portlet, at
In this case, the input will be x, and its output is y
Or you can consider it as taking the x input, and putting it in
The pairing box f, you will manage it
Gives the output y
The set of values ​​we use for x is called a domain
A set of values ​​that can be f
Called domain
And a set of y values ​​that f
Its production, called the range
Now, using this information, let's find, first
The association definitions for each of these issues are these
Issues, and then find domains and ranges
If we have here: Destin gets $ 10.00 per hour - if they call me
Type this at the bottom - $ 10.00 to cut the grass in the hour
How much is the total amount that he gets in conjunction with the hours?
So let's say that Destin gets on, if pairing, I'll call it
D ratio to Destin
The amount obtained by the Dosten in conjunction with the hours
Which depends on the number of hours
The entrance in the box will be
Number of hours worked
The number of hours will be x 10
Ie it will be 10 x - I will not put the multiplication signal here
Maybe I can type 10h
Of course, it can not work for a few negative hours, if we can
Write H to be greater than or equal to
This is the definition of pairing that we have
If we say, how much will he get for a work interview
Half an hour?
You will put 1/2 here, replacing this h
B 1/2
It dissolves 10 x 1/2
Let me write this down on this side
If Dustin will receive a half hour work fee
IE will get 10 - when you see h
You replace it with 1/2 - x 1/2, which equals $ 5.00
This is the definition of pairing that we have
I'd show you an example of how to apply it
Now let's find the domain and range
Domain and scope
I have already said clearly, that you can not
Work for a negative number of hours
This number, this pairing, will be undefined if it is h
Less than 0
If we can say non-negative
Not negative
We can say real numbers, where everything can be
It includes pi and e and all this
But you can not pay
For someone 10 × pi $
The amount is not realistic so you can pay it to someone
Because at the end of the day, it will be you
Bring the amount closer to the nearest penny
So you can not pay that way
If any number will be paid
Relatively few
Which can be written as broken
Therefore we can exclude numbers such as e and pi
If we want to be precise, we can say
Non-negative numbers
Relative numbers
These are the numbers that can be written
Break, which is the majority of numbers, does not include
The numbers that keep repeating are all this
If relative non-negative numbers are what
He can enter it here
Then the range, which is - once again
Any number we put instead of h, remember, you can just put
Non-negative values ​​for h, relative non-negative values
For h, if whatever number we put instead of h, you will
We get positive values ​​that show how much you get in 10h
For pairing values
If again it will be non-negative, if placed
A relative number here and written in a broken way
I beat him by 10, he'll stay
Relative number
Non-negative relative number
If you want to be accurate, you can tell any number
Can be expressed as an amount
But anyway, I do not want to be too precise on this issue
I think you got the idea
Let us solve more
Issues. this is good
Here we are: Maria gives private lessons
You get $ 25.00 per hour tutoring in mathematics so that
The minimum amount you receive is $ 15.00
If the amount you get Maria can be expressed in conjunction with the number of hours
If it gets $ 15.00 if it does not get
Hours are sufficient
If $ 25.00 per hour, in order to get you $ 15.00, you'll
It works by 15/25, ie 3/5 per hour
If its total hours are less than 3/5 and more than or equal to
0, you will get $ 15.00
Because if you worked only 1/5 hours, the price
It will be $ 5.00, but it says it has
Minimum of what you earn is $ 15.00
If you get $ 15.00 up to 3/5 per
Hour, or 36 minutes
And then after that, when h is larger than 3/5
You will receive $ 25.00 per hour
You will get 25 × h
If this is the definition of coupling we have
Now, what is the domain, field
Coupling Maria's wages?
Well, again, this is just an ID
For non-negative numbers
Non-negative numbers
In the same logic we used here, we will be accurate
And say, oh, he can not get e of hours or pi hours
This is not realistic to be measured
Everything can be represented as broken
For example, 5, if I say 5 hours
This is expressed as a break
Which is 5/1
So let's say relative numbers are non-negative
What is the scope of what you gain by breaking or
Coupling?
Well, it would be at least $ 15.00
No matter what, they will earn $ 15.00, if it will
$ 15.00 or more
Which will be in relative numbers and larger
From or equal to $ 15.00
There is no particular situation where you can get $ 14.00
Nor is there a situation that enables it to
Get - $ 1.00
Everything that is produced will be greater than or equal to 15
Now we have a summary of the definitions of conjugation
Thus we can put any number out
Well, we will not deal with
Preparing a vehicle, ie a real setup
But let's see if it is determined by a bit
If we have (f (x
Let me rewrite it. f (x) = 15x - 12
So what is the area here?
What is the field?
Well, I can put any real number x place here and will
Strike it with 15 and subtract from it
Can put pi
I can put here the 2 box
I can put e
I can do many things here
So tell all the real numbers
All the real numbers
Any number of real place I place x, I will get
Logical output
Now what is the range?
.
Well, again, I can take any value here
I can get any negative value if
The value of x is negative
I will subtract it from 12, so I can get any
Negative value
It can get zero
I can get a positive value
If this also will be all real numbers
this is good
Now we have this pairing
(F (x = - they have forgotten the sign of equality -
2x ^ 2 + 5
What is the field?
What are all values ​​that are valid for x and which I can
Put it here?
Well, I can put anything here
I can put e
2e ^ 2 + 5
I can put square root for 2 here
I can put a negative number
If in fact I can take any real number
All real numbers, positive or negative or anything else, or even
Non-relative numbers
Then what is the scope here?
This is interesting
Because it does not matter what number we will put here, this value
Will be greater than zero
Will be, not negative
.
So if you put a negative number here, you'll
You squirt it, and it will become
Positive number when squared
If this term is negative
If you take a non-negative number and add it to 5
You will always get a larger output from or
Equals 5
Even in the worst case, if the value is zero, we will eventually get 5
But if it is either less than zero or slightly
Above zero, you will get values ​​greater than 5
If the range is all the real numbers are bigger
Of or equal to 5
(f) x that we will not take zero value
It is impossible to be worth zero
Question No. 5
We have f (x) = 1 / x
If again, the domain
Well, we can put any value to x
Any real number will succeed here
We will take its upside down
If all the numbers are real, all the numbers will be real
Then what is the range?
It's interesting
Because it does not matter what I put here, I can put anything
Oh, actually, let me relax
Will be undefined when x = 0
All numbers are real except zero
If you put zero here, I'll get 1/0
It will be undefined
Let me write this down
I made a mistake. (f) 0 is not defined
That means we do not know what
We do zero
We did not know how to deal with zero
If f (0) is not defined
If the domain is all real numbers except zero
Now what is the range?
Well, again, we can take any value here except zero
Can approach zero
If the value of x is not very large, very, very, very, very
We can get closer to zero
If the value of x is negative, I will approach zero
But in any case we will not take zero
If again, all real numbers except zero
All real numbers except zero
Okay
Question No. 6
What is the conjugation range y = x ^ 2
- 5 when the domain - has
So deal with the field
They identified it
We were told that the domain is a 2-digit
-1, 0, 1, and 2
If the definition of this pairing says that (f (x
= x ^ 2 - 5 when x = - we can write
Any value for x of this set of values ​​-2
-1, 0, 1, 2
It will not be known if the x is any other value
You will not know what to do with it
You can only apply this if x is one of them
So what is the range?
Well, the range is all combinations, all values ​​are
Can be taken to f (x
If the range will be the set of values ​​we get
When you put different x values
So let's try the first value: -2
2 ^ 2 - 5
Equal to 4-5
= -1
Let's try -1
1 ^ 2 - 5
= 1 - 5
= -4
We have 0
0 ^ 2
If (f) 0, we have 0 ^ 2 - 5, equals 5
We have 1
1 ^ 2 - 5, = -4, if this
Of course it is scale
Then we have 2
2 ^ 2 - 5, this equals -1
It is of course within the field
If these are all values ​​that can be taken for coupling
Where it was determined
To include only these values
.